bonsoir il est 18 heures si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur tv films
nouvelle édition du 7 8 pour faire le
point sur l'actualité locale il sera
question dans quelques minutes de la
semaine du goût avec nos premiers
invités qui sont déjà sur le plateau
vous les avez aperçu jérôme et cévaër
bonsoir sur le vous êtes seul chef de
l'auberge du manet à montigny le
bretonneux chef de cuisine et isabelle
bianchi bonsoir à vous vous êtes maître
restaurateur dans ce même établissement
maître restaurateur
ça signifie quoi que c'est être maître
restaurateur s'est représenté un label
pour les clients de qualité de
savoir-faire de cuisiner des produits
frais et d'assurer aux clients une
qualité certaine qu'il y assez peu
d'établissements qu'il ya très peu
d'établissements il ya 2000
établissements qui ont ce label
aujourd'hui sur 200 milles restaurant et
très peu de femmes et très peu de femmes
si je crois qu'on a deux ou trois
peut-être l'une d'entre elles est sur ce
plateau et on va parler de la semaine du
goût avec vous deux dans un instant je
vous propose pour l'instant de découvrir
les autres sujets que nous allons
aborder au cours de ce 7,8 en images les
travaux de rénovation de la gare de
trappes prennent forme des travaux qui
se déroulent principalement de nuit en
ce moment vous allez voir comment
travaillent les ouvriers pendant votre
sommeil il est compliqué de trouver un
travail aujourd'hui c'est encore plus un
casse-tête console se trouve en
situation de handicap à forum était
organisé sur cette question ou des
demandeurs d'emploi sont venus
directement à la rencontre des
recruteurs l'an passé 75 personnes ont
trouvé ainsi qu'un travail la semaine du
goût c'est en ce moment on en parlait il
ya quelques instants en ateliers étaient
proposés vous le voyez à la maison du
livre quartier du bois de l'étang sera
la verrière à destination des enfants un
diététicien est venu donner est et
conseils pour une bonne alimentation et
puis les fatals picards seront en
concert le samedi 20 octobre à l'abri
blues de bois d'arcy
vous entendrez ce groupe de rock
parodique au cours de notre page culture
présentait comme tous les mercredis par
johanna soudry avant de parler de la
semaine du goût un mot deux politiques
avec une surprise de taille
joël regnault le maire de plaisir a
annoncé lundi lors d'une
union interne son désir de quitter son
poste c'est l'information surprise
relayée par nos confrères des nouvelles
de versailles contacté le service de
communication de la mairie de plaisir
nous a fait savoir que joël regnault
justement avait décidé de passer à la
main nous l'avons joint directement
ensuite par téléphone il nous a expliqué
expliqué préparer les municipales de
2014 et nous a précisé qu'il siègerait
toujours au conseil municipal d'ici là
le conseil municipal le prochain risque
d'être agité ce sera jeudi soir à 20
heures l'élu à la culture joséphine
coleman ce berger serait pressentie pour
devenir la prochaine maire de cette
ville de plaisir à suivre
une information qui sera développé dans
notre prochaine édition du 7 8 demain
judicieux et du côté de la celle saint
cloud à présent le maire olivier
delaporte demande sa réintégration au
sein de l'ump
écarté pour avoir maintenu sa
candidature lors des élections
législatives en juin dernier face à
henri guaino il a pour la seconde fois
fait parvenir un courrier à jean
françois copé secrétaire général du
mouvement courrier sans suite pour le
moment olivier delaporte avait critiqué
le parachutage de l'ancienne plume de
nicolas sarkozy il avait tout de même
retiré sa candidature à l'issue du
premier tour laissant la voie libre à
henri guaino qui était arrivé en tête
on écoute à ce sujet au sujet de la
réintégration de olivier delaporte à
valérie pécresse et la chef de file de
l'ump dans le département des yvelines
elle soutient cette demande de
réintégration formulée par olivier
delaporte on écoute valérie pécresse
vous savez bien que ces questions de
réintégration de candidats dissidents
sont des questions extrêmement sensible
et qu'il faut toujours qu'il y ait un
petit peu de temps qui s'écoule
c'est vrai qu' olivier delaporte et
henri guaino auront une confrontation
assez violente
donc je pense qu'il faut prendre le
temps de calmer tout ça de réconcilier
tous les candidats entre eux et j'espère
moi pouvoir être à la tête d'une famille
très unie à partir de 18 heures
vous souhaitez sa réintégration moi je
souhaite la réconciliation je souhaite
qu'on tourne la page je souhaite qu'on
construise d'avenir parce que l'avenir
c'est les municipales et pour les
municipales olivier delaporte qui est
très solidement ancré à la celle saint
cloud eh bien ce sera un très bon
candidat
j'espère peut-être d'une famille
réconcilier